good evening while the election
continues to dominate the headlines the
coronavirus pandemic is still having a
major
impact on our country thanks for joining
us here at 11 i'm denise valdez and i'm
brian loftis nevada recorded one of the
highest
increases in cases today and the las
vegas raiders are being hit hard for
violating pandemic rules
sports director chris matthews here in
studio now with the consequences the
team is facing
well thank you brian yeah this has
become a very serious problem for the
raiders organization
they've been digged before and today the
league coming down hard again on the
franchise
if there is a poster team of violating
coving protocols it's becoming very
clear
that this is the franchise an example of
what you do not want to do
like any program the responsibility
starts with a head coach john gruden
has been asked repeatedly by the press
over the last month about those coveted
concerns and violations
i'm not going to answer any more of
these questions i'm i'm really confident
that everybody's doing the best they can
you know we are we are doing everything
we can and we we have great confidence
in everybody that we play that they're
doing the best they can
but i'm not going to keep answering
questions about this i hate the virus
we got to rev up our intensity and our
concentration and how to beat it
and that we will do all right that was
almost exactly one month ago
at that point for not following
protocols the team had already been
fined two hundred fifty thousand dollars
gruden a hundred thousand dollars
players were later fined for not wearing
masks at a charity event
now the team gets hit again for repeated
violations it was revealed today
that the nfl has fined the raiders five
hundred thousand dollars
gruden gets fined again this time 150
000 and they will lose a
20-21 sixth-round draft pick more
penalties could be coming if the team
doesn't more diligently follow the rules
and if you add it all up the franchise
coach and players they have shelled out
over 1 million dollars in covid fines
now to be fair the raiders aren't the
only team with coveted violations
but so far they've been smacked the
hardest by the league
we didn't even talk about the players
who battled the virus raiders lineman
trent brown is back on the coveted
reserve list